[Music]
you are a very lucky girl
Miranda Wells will you marry me not many
men would be willing to take on somebody
with your baggage I mean three kids I'm
mounting a death
looking for Miranda Wells she's at work
right now you believe with me I'm her
son
I'm afraid this comes with a little bit
of an explanation
hurricane warning your weather guy says
it's gonna miss us but you never be too
careful no matter how bad things are
they can always get worse mom I'm
expecting a call from the bank ray
Johnson
Miranda Wells there goes my deductible
don't waste your insurance on this why
is he taking your bumper get these offer
to come over to fix it you're letting
him follow us home
youko now you're looking for her and she
runs into you it's pretty weird is it
your thoughts attract things with a
force that you cannot see but is
definitely real okay this is me thinking
about pizza don't look at me have to be
careful Yeah right because we get what
we expect I'm open to the possibility
that whatever happens oh my god even the
bad stuff can lead to better things I
can't afford a new roof let me help
why are you helping me because I can
how do you know Miranda I don't really
why are you fixing a roof I just don't
want you to blow this she doesn't love
him not like dad all your dad ever
wanted was for you to be happy how would
you know that what are you doing right
now taking in this gorgeous sunset I
don't understand what's happening here I
think you and I collided for a reason
what's it say I've been dreamin one fund
involve a pin to the bumper karma or
maybe it's just a lousy driver it's a
better day coming
you